- The best (beep)
organization in the world.
- [Eddie] And what is that?
- (beep) Proud Boys.
- [Eddie] Hell yeah.
- [Man] Whose streets?
- [Marchers] Our streets!
USA! USA!
- [Narrator] One of the
most prominent groups
to storm the Capitol on
January 6th was the Proud Boys,
a right-wing extremist group
whose members describe themselves
as Western chauvinists.
- [Eddie] The Proud
Boys are takin' over DC.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- [Narrator] The Wall Street Journal
analyzed hundreds of videos from the riot,
social media posts, court filings,
and interviewed participants in the events
and experts on extremism in
an effort to piece together
the most complete picture
of the Proud Boys' role
in the events that day.
- [Marchers] USA! USA!
USA! USA!
(beep) Antifa! (beep) Antifa!
- [Narrator] The Journal's investigation
shows Proud Boys coordinating, instigating
and leading some of the
most pivotal moments
of the rush into the historic building
that disrupted lawmaker certification
of the presidential election
and resulted in the death of five people,
including one police officer.
(rioters shouting overlaps)
- Let's go!
- [Narrator] About seven Proud Boys
have been arrested so far for
their actions at the Capitol,
more than any other right-wing
group there that day.
Proud Boy chairman Enrique
Tarrio told The Journal,
"The Proud Boys didn't
coordinate their actions
"or intend to storm the Capitol,"
and many of the threats
that The Journal pointed out
were meant as a joke.
He also said the Proud
Boys don't condone violence
unless in self-defense.
- [Man] Move!
- [Marchers] Move!
- [Narrator] Tarrio wasn't
at the Capitol that day
because he was arrested days before
and charged with destruction of property
and was banned from the city.
(tense music)
(marcher chattering overlaps)
- [Man] Whose streets?
- [Narrator] The Proud Boys first earned
mainstream attention when President Trump
didn't denounce white supremacists
and right-wing militia groups
in a September presidential debate.
- Proud Boys, stand back and stand by,
but I'll tell you what,
I'll tell you what,
somebody's gotta do something
about Antifa and the left.
- [Narrator] The moment
emboldened the group.
Its leader, Enrique Tarrio,
posted a message on
social media shortly after
saying simply, "Standing by sir."
It has been widely reported that the group
planned to attend a rally at
the Capitol on January 6th
to protest election results.
Joe Biggs, another leader,
called for violence on social media.
- [Eddie] All right guys, you
wanna see all the Proud Boys
that are here today?
Here we go.
Everybody cover up!
- [Narrator] On the day of the event,
more than 100 Proud Boys from
around the country were there.
- Montana!
- 406!
- Idaho!
- [Eddie] Like his channel.
- [Narrator] A Proud Boy live
streamer named Eddie Block
extensively filmed the group
as they met and coordinated.
- I know, right?
- [Narrator] Block declined to comment.
- I know, exactly.
- [Narrator] In the morning,
before a rally near the White
House with President Trump,
the Proud Boys meet on the
east side of the Capitol.
Biggs can be seen organizing
groups of Proud Boys.
He's equipped with a radio.
- [Joe] If you're on the outside,
makin' sure you're looking on
the outside of the perimeter,
no one's sneakin' up on us.
- [Narrator] Biggs has since been arrested
and charging documents
say he aided, abetted,
and commanded others to
unlawfully enter the Capitol.
- [Eddie] The big boss man, Joe Biggs.
- [Narrator] Biggs and his attorney
did not respond to multiple
requests for comment.
- Milkshake's afraid of me
'cause I'm gonna kick his (beep).
- [Narrator] Dan Scott, a
Proud Boy known as Milkshake,
can be heard shouting.
- [Dan] Let's take the (beep) Capitol!
- [Man] Come on, tighten up.
Tighten up, tighten up.
- Come on, boys.
- [Man] Tighten up, tighten up!
- [Narrator] But is chastised by others.
- None of that.
Let's not (beep) yell that, all right?
- It was Milkshake, man. He knows.
(Eddie laughs)
Idiot.
- [Dan] Don't yell it, do it.
- [Narrator] Scott did not respond
to multiple requests for comment.
- [Men] (beep) Antifa!
- [Narrator] Some individuals,
who would hours later
participate in the riot,
can be seen taking part in the rendezvous.
There's Michael Porter
who identified himself to
The Journal as a Proud Boy.
This man, whose identity The
Journal could not fully confirm
in interviews, social media
searches and court documents,
can be seen with the
group throughout the day,
instigating the mob.
And Robert Gieswein,
who's also with the
group throughout the day
and is wearing patches
suggesting affiliation
with Proud Boys and right-wing groups.
- [Eddie] (laughs) I
gotta get one of these.
- [Narrator] Rallied by Biggs
and another leader, Ethan
Nordean, known as Rufio,
the Proud Boys coalesce
and march on the Capitol.
Nordean declined to comment.
- [Eddie] Two men on a mission
with about 500 behind them,
ready to kick some butt
and stand up for this country.
(tense music)
- [Cameraman] Saw the
Proud Boys comin' in.
- [Narrator] At around 12:50 p.m.,
while President Trump has taken
the stage at a nearby rally,
another live streamer
captures the Proud Boys
approaching the Capitol from the northwest
and encountering a small police presence
behind a temporary barrier.
- [Crowd] We love Trump!
We love Trump!
- [Narrator] Biggs
huddles with an individual
in a red hat and carrying a flag.
- [Crowd] We love Trump!
We love Trump!
- So basically...
- [Man] Yeah, kill the speech.
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] Who just minutes later
is the first to charge the barriers.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Man] Someone hold my pack.
Hold my backpack.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hold my backpack.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
(fencing clatters)
- USA! USA!
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Narrator] Proud Boys
can be seen in the crowd.
Porter told The Journal that
he participated in a protest,
not a riot, and that he
did not enter the Capitol.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Man] Stop them! Storm the Capitol!
- [Narrator] The few police officers there
quickly fall back.
And the Proud Boys make up a large portion
of the first wave to reach
the base of the Capitol.
- [Man] They're rushing the
(beep) Capitol, brother!
The Proud Boys are rushin' the Capitol!
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Narrator] Proud Boys are
among those who square off
with Capitol Police at
the base of the building.
(tense music)
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Man] We just took the US Capitol.
- [Narrator] Dominic Pezzola,
a Proud Boy and military
veteran known as Spazzo
is on the frontlines
with a wire in his ear.
Pezzola's attorney told The Journal
his client did not coordinate
his actions with anyone
and that the radio earpiece
was for listening to music.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Woman] Traitor!
- [Narrator] This man,
who continues to be seen
with the Proud Boys,
appears to be directing members of the mob
to the left side of the police line.
- Come back at the
standing, grab a brother.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Narrator] He then leads a chant.
- [Man] Whose country is this?
- [Crowd] Our country!
- [Man] Whose house is this?
- [Crowd] Our house!
- Do you want your house back?
- [Crowd] Yes!
- Take it!
- [Narrator] Gieswein is nearby.
- [Protester] Take it!
- [Man] What now?
[Narrator] Nordean, Biggs,
and other leadership
also take prominent
places on the frontline
near the Capitol steps.
(tense music)
(crowd chattering overlaps)
- Look at (beep), thinks they're hard!
But they're-
- [Narrator] A protracted
battle between rioters
and outnumbered police ensues
and Proud Boys like Pezzola
can be seen throughout key
parts of the confrontation.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- (beep) you!
(beep) you!
- [Man] (beep) you!
- [Narrator] Around 1:37,
Gieswein tries to push
through the police barriers.
- [Man] Can't push us, patriots!
- [Narrator] And an hour later,
rioters try to flank the
police by climbing scaffolding.
(rioter shouting overlaps)
- [Man] Go!
- [Narrator] Pezzola
takes part in the charge.
- [Man] (beep) you!
(beep) you!
- [Man] We takin' this (beep).
- [Narrator] And Gieswein sprays police
with an unidentified substance.
(tense music)
Gieswein was arrested for
assaulting a federal officer,
destruction of government property,
entering a restricted area,
and disrupting Congress.
Gieswein's attorney declined to comment.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
(glass clattering)
- [Man] They're breakin' the window!
- [Narrator] At around 2:12,
Pezzola breaks a window to the
Capitol with a police shield.
- Go, go, go, go, go!
- Let's go!
- [Narrator] He and Gieswein
are among the first rioters
to enter the building.
(crowd shouting overlaps)
- [Man] Go!
(Dominic shouting)
- [Narrator] Pezzola was
arrested on January 15th
for unlawful entry, destruction
of government property,
and obstruction of an official proceeding.
- [Dominic] Let's go!
(rioter shouting overlaps)
- [Man] Hey, where're
they countin' the votes?
(beep) where do they count the votes?
- Put it down!
- Where they countin'?
- [Narrator] Inside the Capitol,
a crowd of rioters encounter
Officer Eugene Goodman.
They follow him up a set of stairs.
- Second floor!
- [Narrator] Coming perilously
close to the lawmakers
who are just down the hall
through the doorway to
the left of Goodman.
(tense music)
(crowd shouting overlaps)
Pezzola and Gieswein are in the crowd.
- [Rioter] This is ours!
- [Narrator] Entering the
building close behind is Biggs.
- [Woman] (beep) you!
- [Cameraperson] Biggs,
what you gotta say?
- This is awesome.
(rioters shouting)
- [Tyler] It's over!
- [Narrator] Around the same time
at the base of the building,
the police line is breaking apart
and crowds storm more entrances.
(crowd cheering)
At larger groups of rioters
breach the building,
parts of the Proud Boys
contingent make it inside.
Nicholas Ochs,
leader of the Hawaii chapter
of the Proud Boys, was arrested
after boasting about entering
the Capitol on social media.
Ochs and his attorney declined to comment.
- I'm right here.
- Onwards!
- [Narrator] According
to the charging documents
for Miami Proud Boy, Gabriel
Garcia, he roamed the Capitol
calling for Nancy Pelosi to
quote, "Come out and play."
A lawyer for Garcia said that
he did not damage property
or commit violence at the Capitol.
His comments about Pelosi were in jest
and he wants nothing to
do with the Proud Boys.
(tense music)
- [Man] Ho!
Ho!
- [Narrator] Since the riot,
Proud Boys leadership has
tried to downplay their role.
But The Journal's investigation
shows that at every key breach
of the Capitol's defenses,
the Proud Boys and members
of their contingent
are at the forefront of the mob
and can be seen coordinating
and instigating.
Authorities have arrested
about seven Proud Boys so far
for their role in the attack.
Other Proud Boys have
threatened more violence.
- Take this as a shot across the bow.
Like, next time we come armed.
- [Narrator] Porter told The Journal
he made this statement as an individual,
not as a representative of the Proud Boys.
Proud Boy leadership was
unapologetic about the violence
in a live stream after the riots.
- I've answered reporters
for the past week
that keep saying, "Well,
the Proud Boys planned this
and this is (beep) up."
And they've told me to denounce it.
Listen, I'm not gonna denounce anything.
I do understand-
- [Narrator] Tarrio told The Journal
that his and Biggs' comments in this show
were expressing the
views of Trump supporters
who have felt marginalized by the system.
- It's only going to get worse
and that's what people don't understand,
is the more you push the bear,
the more you poke the bear,
the bear is going to (beep) come back.
(tense music)